das ist sehr gut so wunderschön sonnig
ist es ist viel passiert er in letzter
zeit bei mir und gerade deshalb ist die
lage gut hast du damit gerechnet
es hat sich im laufe der vorbereitung
auf das album langsam angedeutet dass es
weit nach oben gehen könnte aber es ist
wirklich so weit nach oben geht hätte
keiner für möglich gehalten aber umso
schöner
wie hat sich das bedeutet dann merkt man
so was du merkst es einen klicks
natürlich dass du hast als erstes die
resonanz auf seine youtube videos ganz
ein bisschen drunter lesen was die leute
so schreiben und wie die like
verhältnisse sind daumen hoch daumen
runter und dann kriegt man natürlich
auch feedback von der szene und von
leuten mit dem man zusammen arbeitet und
dann hat man ein gutes gefühl und als
musiker selbst hat man ja auch sowieso
das musikalische gefühl dass das was man
da gemacht hat das ist dass es cool
ankommen könnte das ist das ist richtig
dass verpackt was ich denke und das ist
gleichzeitig aber auch den hörer
irgendwie treffen kann
wann man kann das planen also die videos
sind ja super gelaufen
auf youtube millionen klicks ist das
etwas fast von sich aus kommt oder ist
das wird kann man das in irgendeiner
weise steuern oder geht das ja jetzt
automatisch oder
was wir dafür tun damit man so
erfolgreich wird so erfolgreich wird als
jemand der vorher noch kein album kein
chart andromache dafür diese ganzen
label mechanismen da müsste man jetzt
natürlich mein label befragen meine in
meine jungs meine trailerpark jungs die
sich da wirklich krass ins zeug gelegt
haben dass da dass er alle kontakte
genutzt werden die man so hat in szene
zu irgendwelchen medien zu den hip hop
medien mit dem man erst mal angefangen
hat und das ist aber überhaupt gar nicht
mein metier ich bin ja er war nur ganz
stumpf und naiv am musikmachen das
vorantreiben was ich da was mit deinem
kopf herum schwebt und da will ich auch
gar nicht denken von irgendwelchen wann
was ein pressetermin machen wir dann und
wann und mit wem auch ich ein interview
darüber
das ist mir alles zu wieder darüber
nachzudenken weil ich mich lieber auf
die musik konzentrieren
deswegen bin ich froh dass da diese
hebel gedrückt wurden die das ganze nach
vorne bringen und ich natürlich aber mit
meiner musik auch den denk ich mal nicht
unerheblichen teil dazu beigetragen habe
hast du interviews nein ich bin es ich
bin es noch gar nicht so lange gewohnt
überhaupt gefragt zu werden
zu meiner person zu meiner musik vor
allem zu meiner musik wurde ich lange
nicht gefragt ich habe gerade zweiter
2006 mache ich jetzt musik mache ich
alligator konkret auch und man hat eine
lange zeit einfach veröffentlicht
veröffentlicht veröffentlicht und hatte
nur das internet als als publikum hatte
ins internet download alben gestellt und
dass man jetzt aber wirklich mal
dass die gelegenheit quasi bekommt
darüber zu sprechen über die inhalte von
den songs über die themen die mir da
durch den kopf gegangen
das ist was schönes eigentlich es gibt
leute die sagen das stimmt meine kunst
als künstler waren moment will ja gar
nicht dafür hinterfragt wird aber das
ist wirklich keine kein problem ich kann
mich hinsetzen und sagen bei dem song
möchte ich nicht dass das ich dazu jetzt
eine meinung äußere oder so über dem
sagen möchte ich da so stehen lassen
aber ich bin auf jeden fall bereit mich
hinzusetzen und zu sagen so meine ich
das so sollt ihr da oder so weit will
ich euch da hinweise geben oder so weit
kann ich euch dazu anstupsen da euch
selbst die gedanken zu machen welche
fonds würdest du lieber so stehen lassen
interessant wurde sagt da bin ich nicht
überreden ich kann über alles reden aber
du wirst zu den meisten songs die
antwort bekommen
da wird diese seite gezeigt und auch
diese seite und auf welche seite man
sich jetzt schlägt da möchte ich nichts
zu sagen dass es das es jedem selbst
überlassen wobei wenn ich jetzt willst
du mit mir drogen nehmen
er höre dann ist er relativ eindeutig
auf welcher seite du stehst oder hab ich
das falsch gehört naja es ist es ist
eindeutig dass im reform den bach
heruntergegangen hält das ist klar dass
ich
singe das eine normale drogenkarriere
höchstwahrscheinlich im keller endet
dass es gibt ausnahmen aber ausnahmen
bestätigen die regel dass ist das will
ich nicht bestreiten bestätigen
aber ich bin zudem niemand der sich
hinsetzt mit dem zeigefinger und sagt
ich möchte mich gegen drohungen
aussprechen oder ich bin jetzt der
sprecher für keine macht den drogen oder
so das würde ich habe niemals machen
dass das ist nicht meine aufgabe
meine aufgabe ist die beobachtung zu
schildern und ein lied darüber zu machen
dass deine erfahrung wie sind deine
erfahrung mit drogen ich habe mit
chemischen drogen keine erfahrung ich
habe keine erfahrung mit also keine
direkten erfahrungen damit ich habe ich
habe umfeld erfahrungen aus meinem
umfeld und ich bin in allen bereichen
sehr tolerant und jedem jedem das seine
lasse ich so stehen ich möchte möchte
niemandem dazwischen reden aber ich kann
durchaus da meine eigenen meine eigene
meinung hat daraus ziehen und meine
meine gedanken darüber ob es jetzt sinn
macht sich vor der show diverse pillen
ein zu schmeißen um dann am ende des
abends kostet im klo zu legen und dann
die nächsten drei tage keine auftritte
mehr spielen zu können
es gibt ja viele künstler die in
anführungszeichen brauchen das ist das
keine situation die unglaublich
angespannt ist ich sag mal das ist
wahrscheinlich auch
es ist ja nicht einfach auf die bühne zu
gehen oder wie ist es anstrengend vor
allem und es ist es ist auch mein
persönlicher anspruch den ich habe weil
ich möchte ja eine gute show liefern und
und keine halbgare keine halbgare
geschichte da abliefern
und es gibt leute die können das sie
können auf diversen drogen geile show
liefern da muss es auch so sein und dann
ist das ja auch gut so aber wie gesagt
rock 'n' roll muss man auch können
du hast sehr großen respekt davor ja und
ich habe auch nicht so wirklich
interesse daran ist es ist es wie gesagt
man kann vielleicht durch drogen kann
man sich sicherlich das ein oder andere
hochgefühl erschleichen oder eben auch
die angst betreuen weil es ist ja schon
eher
das ist ja nicht leicht auf die bühne zu
gehen und warm ist sich ja vor dem
publikum mal das ist richtig aber man
nimmt sich auch wiederum damit etwas
weil du baust anja eine wand irgendwie
auf die dir zwar die die negativen
emotionen wie aufregung und nervosität
vielleicht nehmen aber die dir auch dann
gar nicht erlauben daraus das komplette
hochgefühl zu ziehen kann man denn in
dieser in der musikbranche ist ja drogen
sind da gang und gäbe die gen rom kann
man da bestehen also ich sag mal wie
wird es auf der einen oder anderen party
wahrscheinlich so ergangen sein dass wir
immer oder willst du willst du genau
informieren völlig unterliegt das ist ja
immer total blöde situation wenn man
sich jetzt so ein bisschen außen auch
aus rausstellt aus der aus der gruppe
wie gehst du damit um diese okay so
schlimm ist es dann auch nicht mehr so
lange noch nicht in dieser musikszene
kreisen drin
wer weiß was noch passiert aber
mittlerweile also bis jetzt habe ich
noch überhaupt keine probleme damit
gehabt er ist es so dass das ich gerne
sage dass ich derjenige bin der ich
finger von lässt weil das weil man sich
damit ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen
zurückzieht ich bin auch jemand der sich
gerne mal zurückzieht
auch das auch irgendwann irgendwann ja
nachdem ich dann genug alkohol
verköstigt habe ok also alkohol liefern
ja da muss ich dann leider doch sagen da
ist das ist meine achillesferse der
nicht an doch ich komme vom dorf ich
habe da doch dann auch gesündigt
ich bin da ich bin da nicht ganz
schulfrei aber ich trinke auf tour nicht
mehr zum beispiel trinke vor konzertende
konzerten gar nichts mehr denn es ist
mir dann doch wichtiger eine gute
performance darzubieten
und das würde die mit alkohol schwer
fallen es würde auf dauer nicht gutgehen
alkohol greift die stimme sehr an
ich habe die doppelbelastung weil ich
rede und singe sollte die stimme auf der
kompletten höhe sein am besten wie ist
das jetzt für dich als jemand der im
jahre lang musik macht aber jetzt
plötzlich ja dieser große erfolg kommt
ist dass eine komplette umstellung oder
ist es etwas das wir in all den jahren
wurde würde ich quasi darauf vorbereitet
hat der mann hat sich schon darauf
vorbereitet weil es halt schritt für
schritt immer größer wurde und das ist
ja nicht so es ist ja wie diese
dieser teich wo man natürlich keine
fische von oben sieht und dann taucht
irgendwann fisch auf aber das heißt
nicht dass das der fisch vorher nicht da
gewesen ist der ist er hat er vorher
auch seinen weg irgendwie nach oben
gemacht und da waren viele fische und
dass deswegen habe ich natürlich diese
diese diesen langsam weg nach oben
gemacht und konnte mich langsam und mehr
und mehr mit dem gedanken anfreunden und
deswegen dieses über nacht zum star
werden gibt's da glaube ich auch nicht
mehr so wirklich nicht man hat nur neues
level quasi nur neue stufe erreicht
diese stufe war vielleicht größer als
die stufen zuvor aber vom von der
entwicklung her ist es kein unterschied
ist es nichts anderes kommt plötzlich
neue fans dazu genau wie leicht sich in
anders sind als die alten fans für das
pendant wird sich gerne bekriegt in den
kommentaren auch das ist großes
streitthema auch gerne denn denn die
alten fans sind natürlich nicht
begeistert davon dass jetzt kleine
mädchen
meine songs posten auf facebook und dann
gibt es streit dann wird sich und das
ist herrlich ich gucke mir gerne zu was
also passiert aber nichts beobachter gut
was hältst du von dieser veränderung
auch im publikum
ich schaue mir das an ich steuert das ja
nicht bewusst was für ein publikum sich
dann an sammelt ich glaube aber dass der
durchschnittliche hörer meiner musik
dadurch dass man bei meiner musik ein
bisschen auf die texte achten muss um es
zu verstehen dass der durchschnittliche
hörer da schon bereit ist längerfristig
sich dieser sache zugehörig zu fühlen
das ist es gibt es gibt da so eine was
ich beobachten konnte eine gewisse
gemeinschaft auch unter diesen diesen
leuten die sagen dass sie dass sie meine
musik hören da gibt es foren und da
wird sich auf facebook angeregt
unterhalten denn das was in was meine
musik mitbringt ist auch ein kleines
kleines universum da gibt es die
verschiedenen figuren die terroristen
und die die sie lustig verkleideten
menschen und das alles herauszufinden da
bedarf es einfach zeit und da bedarf es
halt diese diesen gewissen engagement
dran zu bleiben wenn du jetzt so social
media beobachtest kannst du da
eigentlich sehen wie sich deine texte
auswirken wie wird das diskutiert wie
sich die als zuhörer was mit deinen
texten anfangen können und ob sie in
ihren alltag einfließen sagen ja ich
habe da und da hat dass du das haus
gehört das finde ich eine gute sache
weil uns ja dass das kann man hin und
wieder beobachten unter den oder den
videos in den kommentaren das was ich
eben schon gesagt habe diese dieser
kampf der dann immer stattfindet unter
den leuten das natürlich dann zu
beobachten weil sich dann natürlich auch
gerne damit profiliert wird dass man
selbst den song am besten verstanden
hätte und das andere nicht verstanden
haben dann ist es wieder so czech die
message nicht und das geht doch gar
nicht darum ihr seid alle blöd ich
möchte das top kommentar bitte sein
unter diesem video
ja ich finde es witzig dass zu
beobachten wie gesagt und aber dann
dennoch immer wieder schön wenn man halt
auch dann zu sehen ist das dass die
message zumindest anregt oder dass das
der song halt anstößt gedanken anstößt
und dass man sich damit beschäftigt
allein das ist es ja schon wenn du die
chance hast du das schon im kopf dass du
was damit bewegt oder ist das eine neben
so weit bin ich glaube ich noch nicht
beim schreiben das ist das ist wichtig
ist mir dass ich das thema was mir
gerade im kopf ist erstmal gut zu papier
bringen gut in lyrik verpacken kann
und ja wenn es gut läuft hat man damit
halt ein thema erwischt was was auch ein
politikum ist sagt man dass man was sich
auch diskutieren lässt bei drogen nehmen
ist das ja ein thema oder das ist ja
quasi gesetzt oder die unausweichlich
dass man dazu diskussion anregt und was
bewirkt
trotzdem wenn du dir darüber gedanken
macht spielt das erst mal keine rolle
das spielt das spielt keine rolle was
ich damit für für leute erreichen könnte
und wenn ich damit meine ich damit
irgendwie zu was für gedanken anregen
würde mir ist am ende des songs wichtig
dass ich ein reines gewissen dabei habe
das ich guten gewissens sagen kann ja
dass das da steckt alles drin was was
mir entspricht und was nicht irgendwie
zu in zu falsche hände geraten kann
und dann sehe ich das also nach dem
emotionalen ausbruch nach dem ich alles
raus gelassen habe kommt noch einmal
kurz der kopf filter okay das ist kann
man so stehen lassen die leute werden
verstehen was ich meine dass meine
botschaft friedlich ist und dass ich ein
lieber mensch bin und dann kann ich das
auch guten gewissens raus
das ist ihm wichtig damals gibt der
andere beispiel 20 gangsta-rapper sagen
dass es eine rolle dass spiele ich ja
nur das ist wie im film den actionfilm
wo sie auch viele tote gibt
aber die botschaft ist ja nicht dass man
bei den umbringen sondern es ist eine
kunstform stimmte zudem zu oder sagst du
kann er für die gelben geht nicht für
mich oder hast du dich dafür entschieden
das nicht zu machen weil das gilt
insbesondere für mich weil ich nenne
meine monster auch schauspiel im rap und
bin ja auch bin ja auch immer so daran
gegangen was ich da mache sind filme das
wäre ja nicht ich von dem was ich da
darstelle
das da ist fließt auch blut da gibt es
explosionen aber trotzdem so ist die
message korrekt ich noch mal die messe
trotzdem ein oder andere gangster nicht
unbedingt frieden
ja aber das ist das ist halt wie rambo
film hast da wird auch nur drauflos
geschossen
vielleicht ein takeshi kitano film hast
wo auch wie viel blut fließt aber wo hat
man auch in den bildern erkennen wo das
message mäßig vielleicht hingehen könnte
beides hat blut aber sind
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen und
unterschiedliche ausdrucks die zweite
steht er bisher meine form formel oder
wie wenn man jetzt full metal jacket
nimmt das auch ein kriegsfilm aber also
da fließt blut da werden leute
erschossen
ja aber nicht um zu zeigen wie cool es
ist eine waffe zu haben
das ist ihm wichtig das ist mir in
meiner musik wichtig ich bin aber auch
niemand der das andere nicht mag okay
und ich auch gerne mal rambo film guckt
okay du würdest auch den anderen rapper
store aber du wirst ja weil ich machen
ich will dich selber nicht machen aber
ich höre lieber als meine eigenen
verständlich man hört er nicht seine
eigene musik das ist ja verpönt
den ganzen tag spiegel über dem bett
angebracht
findest du dich damals wie ich mich als
künstler als person man sich nun eben
die stelzen wie findest du sagst du
super habe ich gut gemacht oder sagst du
wieder mist aber ich will sich besser
hin oder die bandbreite wenn du sagst
ich kann finden der andere muss ich
besser als meine kann es hören oder
kannst du das nicht sagen wie du dich
bin ich bin zufrieden mit mir okay bin
ich glaube ich bin zufrieden mit mir und
wenn ich sage dass ich anderen muss ich
lieber höre als meine heißt es ja nicht
dass ich andere musik besser finden
die sammelklage handlung wenn man wenn
man selbst einen song aufnimmt und dann
da wochen land teilweise daran rum
schnibbelt und sogar ein video zu dreht
und den immer wieder hört dann hat man
den von von berufswegen ja schon oft
genug tod gehört das kann man sich an
die männer
ich höre mir dann vielleicht jetzt mein
aktuelles album in einem halben jahr mal
wieder an und freue mich darüber wie ich
das tor gemacht habe und ja dass man war
das schön war das schön du und dann
wieder gangster nachhinein dein album
oder musik von dr
ist das ein gefühl von ja super passt
alles ist alles aus einem guss oder
denkst du manchmal auch gott das hätte
ich jetzt doch anders kann man jetzt mit
abstand anders mit abstand bin ich
eigentlich zunehmend zunehmend
wohlwollen damit mir selbst ich glaube
nach dem so ein album fertig ist ist man
da ein wacklig man hat ja alles raus
gelassen
hat ist verzweifelt an einigen an
einigen stellen wirklich tatsächlich mit
dem kopf gegen die wand gelaufen und ist
auch sich manchmal sogar unsicher
richtig und weisheit macht man es halt
einfach lässt es so stehen und gibt es
raus und hatten nicht mehr an und fast
das lieber nicht mehr an um nicht noch
mehr zu zerstören und dann da muss es
auch einfach mal gut sein denn sonst
würde nichts passieren wenn ich ein
perfektionist wäre dann würde niemals
was rauskommen wahrscheinlich weil weil
das alles nicht gut genug wäre das gar
nicht vorstellen aber ich lasse das dann
gerne mal schwimmen und wenn ich das
dann mit dem abstand der zeit wieder mal
mir anschauen und anhören dann dann
funktioniert es besser dann kann ich
mich besser drauf einlassen und auch
besser sehen dass alles doch einen
großen sinn hat ok also nicht der moment
wo man sagt ich würde heute alles anders
waren
auf gar keinen fall selbst meine alten
sachen die schreckliche tonqualität
haben würde ich manchmal gerne an und
denke ja irgendwie war das stimmig für
die zeit und so musste es sein
ist das wenn du das alles bis zum
heutigen tag beobachtet ist das alles
stimmig oder hättest du manchmal
vielleicht folien album veröffentlicht
später anders
das ist alles stimmig es ist alles gut
gelaufen es gab dinge die so gelaufen
sind
dass einflüsse darauf gekommen sind die
ich nicht in der hand hatte manchmal
sind sachen vielleicht wegen
irgendwelcher umstände später oder
früher gekommen
aber im nachhinein ist es alles ist
alles gut man kann damit arbeiten man
kann mit mit dem schicksal was passiert
einfach sowas online romes das kann man
genauso in die kunst einfließen lassen
ein instrument was gerade gesagt nach
dem album fertig hat ist man einfach was
passiert dann wird man wirst du krank
oder wie äußert sich das
ich habe ja gar keine zeit zu lernen da
muss dann muss ja weitergehen man video
und dann machen fotos fürs cover und und
und und und die pressetermine
wahrscheinlich werde ich jetzt wenn
dieser ganze presse rummel vorbei ist
auch erst wirklich zusammenbrechen weil
es ja man ist ja wrack im gedanklichen
sinne im ideen im kreativen sinne
deswegen deswegen gibt es halt auch
phasen schaffensphasen wo man wo einem
partout einfach nichts einfällt weil man
ideen ja nicht nicht einfach so fordern
kann
dann spielt computer oder stumpfe
stumpfsinnige dinge die stiftung für
sinnlichkeit zurückbringen in mein leben
computerspielen ist glaube ich ein sehr
stumpfes nächsten dinge die es dann also
ich spiele sehr sehr selten
computerspiele aber wenn dann richtig
und dann richtig stumpf dann richtig
wenn dann richtig heißt tage und wochen
oder länger so eine nacht vielleicht
durch und dann reicht's auch wieder da
kommen die ideen dann bestenfalls kommen
sie wieder wenn nicht dann doch nur
nacht ist das ist sehr unterschiedlich
man geht daher oft wenn man ihn braucht
durch die durch himmel und hölle durch
und versucht immer die die wieder
wiederkehrenden motive zu finden was ist
passiert als ich die letzte idee hat wo
war ich da man geht an die orte zurück
man versucht irgendwie dieses künstlich
wieder zu erzeugen aber ein dass man
sich ungünstig aber man merkt dann dass
die ideen dann wieder doch ganz woanders
kommen wie man es dann überhaupt nicht
erwartet hätte
deswegen muss man sich in so eine art
entspannungs modus und auch stumm
persönlichkeit so modus manchmal einfach
rein gegeben dass der kauf dass der kopf
irgendwann gar nicht anders kann als
ideen zu fuß gesetzt wurde verraten
meditation
vielleicht kommt ja durchaus das ist
eine art meditation sinnvolles mit oft
passiert genau das
dass es diese dieses weiße licht was man
einfach nur im schädel haben möchte und
das ist dann das wo man was drauf
projizieren kann oder was aussah war ja
das ist dann die die weiße leinwand auf
der man malen kann wieder die man sich
erst mal frei schaufeln muss wenn deine
idee kommen das ist der moment gekommen
die idee es kommen viele ideen aber
viele ideen führen auch zu nichts dann
denkt man darüber nach und merkt dass
wird das wird nicht gut wenn ich eine
idee habe die die potenzial hat wenn ich
sie wenn sie mir in den kopf gefallen
kommt dann ist es dann ist es ein
hektisches gefühlen bin ich aufgeregt
dann ist es dann ist es wie wenn ein
hund gassi gehen möchte dann dann renne
ich richtig wohnung und schreibe auch
machen wir viele notizen und mache
schnell skizzen und dann geht es auch
oft sehr schnell entgegen zu dem
trockenen langen warten auf die ideen
manchmal auf die linke seite ein jahr
für ideen und produktion ich habe
ich habe letzten spätsommer herbst
angefangen 2012 songs aufzunehmen ideen
zu sammeln aufzuschreiben ins studio zu
gehen und im mai diesen jahres war dann
alles im kasten
eine intensive phase dann kommen sie
nicht sein wenn die nächsten ideen
kommen die man wie wir heute gelernt
haben nicht fordern kann
es wird weitergehen es wird weitere
alben gehen gegeben definitiv ich habe
zunächst 1 1 während also mit meiner
band trailer park in planung
was
was kommen wird und die jungs bringen
natürlich auch noch ihre alben und ich
werde auf jeden fall
ich werde die die ideen die jetzt schon
wieder blühen die jetzt schon wieder
fast reif sind werde ich dann auch
pflücken und werde dann auch wieder neue
sachen machen wann weiß man aus velen
will noch bei denen es fehlt noch an
konkreten sachen aber ich bin
zuversichtlich dass da dass da noch was
das feld noch nicht abgeerntet ist noch
eine menge ideen viele viel weißes licht
und erstmal triebwerk gehören sowieso
vielen dank danke dir